[Music]
have y'all ever met before no but um we
got a chance to chop it up in the back
okay okay and he told me he's going to
let me reenact the scene that that's
right was showing I'm going to show him
some stunts I know I'm like man can I
tell you something I've only ever been
to one basketball game yeah and I saw
this man oh really that's the one the
one basketball game was Nick's heat and
uh and you guys won yeah
well how we do that's how we do it had
nothing to do with me being there I
think you I'm going to take some credit
he has no Talent over there um no were
you into sports growing up though yeah I
soccer like so you're football football
football yeah I just did a translation I
know you were being nice all my friends
are going to be like what are you
talking about I know I know America we
just took the name and ran with it with
a different sport you're welcome compl
different game I like it but I it's a
that's a hard one though that's a lot of
cardio soccer did you ever play I did
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I played every
single day what I did every lunch break
in the morning morning and the evening
yeah I was obsessed oh my God don't you
but I wasn't an athlete well you know
that's that's why my dream didn't come
true you know wait wait if you know you
have to work so hard and uh you do but
wait you're playing every day if I'm
playing every day I'm calling myself an
a athlete that's what that's what I'm
calling myself wait so okay so wait was
there anything you ever grew up doing
that you loved but you weren't good at
yes okay we want to hear that cuz you're
so excellent at basketball what did you
suck at Dwayne singing oh singing yeah
oh now I want to do a Koke with you me
too every day terrible at it every day
in the shower everywhere well your
daughter can sing so she got it for me
okay all right all well explain the show
masters of the air for everybody uh
Monsters of the air is is is about the
the bombers that came over to England in
World War II uh who who saved the world
you know these guys are real life
superheroes um yeah uh they put
themselves in the most volatile
situations known to mankind you know 77%
of these guys went down you know and uh
yeah it's the most violent atmosphere
ever known to mankind and what's
beautiful about the show is you get to
experience that you see them in the in
the skies and and it's gory it's
horrible but then you see them come back
down to earth and and and deal with that
trauma and that grief and um we would
call that PTSD now yeah they didn't know
what that was and they had to somehow
find it inside themselves to get back up
and and go again yeah it's amazing what
we asked of people without knowing
you know what it was yeah we wouldn't be
here without them I definitely wouldn't
and yeah absolutely so you get to play a
soldier so little known fact about me I
used to steal my brother's GI Jo's and I
loved playing with soldiers and they
never thought girls wanted to do that I
did with the Barbies and the Barbies
were gigantic compared to them they go
yeah they were no the Barbies
annihilated them but I but I play with J
Jo as like a soldier but I hear that you
have a fun action figure that you grew
up with it wasn't that y'all you didn't
grew up with G Joe you grew up we had
action man was what it was called action
action man yeah okay it does what it
says on the tin it's very
self-explanatory I also had the Street
Sharks we heard you like Street Sharks
and I often buy toys a lot cuz I have
kids so we found some Street Sharks for
you oh my
God we found those for you yeah you want
one yeah I'm not even kidding my Barbie
would have whooped their behinds too for
sure they were just this got the roller
skates and everything exactly all right
they look fancy I like that we didn't
have that all right well let's take
let's take another quick break beating
himself up it's a lot of therapy there
okay uh calum's new series masters of
the a is streaming now it's incredible
it's on Apple TV plus y'all got to check
it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home